hey Rick and Morty fans rejoice they
finally confirmed season four and a
whopping 70 episode order from Adult
Swim so I'll explain what that means
because a lot of people are like is that
seven seasons of 10 episodes apiece or
is that five seasons of 14 episodes of
peace there's a lot that goes into that
we have comic-con coming up this summer
they're gonna do a big panel for that so
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the Rick
and Morty because this is such awesome
news and because the season 3 DVD is
dropping I'm doing a giveaway for that
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I have a deleted scenes that I'll
air at the end of this video too after
we talk about season 4 stuff we're
probably not gonna get season 4 episodes
until July of next year at the earliest
because based on some of the things that
Dan Harmon's said while they were
negotiating back and forth between Dan
and Justin's camp and their agents and
Adult Swim's lawyers it sounded like
they didn't do any work on the season in
all the other people like the producers
the animators went on to other projects
it's totally possible that they worked
this deal out a little while ago and
they started work on it and then they
just waited to announce it
Dana Justin posted this video this
morning in celebration I'm always here
Dan you know that well I guess you know
you don't usually stand all the way up I
know but that's because I've got to get
going Dan I can't live in your shower
anymore like I always do where are you
going buddy I gotta get back to work Dan
we both do
see you soon Dan at the work place we
got to get back
I guess it's time to go but the reason
why it was so important for Adult Swim
to close this deal with Danny Justin
right now is one because the fans are
getting matter in matter they want to
know about season four but also the TV
up fronts are happening really soon in
its staffing season so what happens
during up fronts is this network show
advertisers their upcoming programming
in the more attractive the shows that
they're going to have are the more
likely big advertisers are to spend
money on the network so networks
obviously like to earn money Adult
Swim's biggest show is Rick and Morty
season 3 was the number one show amongst
Millennials anywhere in the world
meaning that they have this big
powerhouse but they can't sell any
advertising against it if they don't
have a new season 2 premiere which is
why this deadline was so important to
them so they've been negotiating since
season three ended and Dan and Justin
also signed a new overall deal with the
network which is basically Adult Swim
locking them down for the next seven
years or so if you're not big on inside
baseball TV stuff what that means is
when you get signed to an overall deal
the network gains a measure of
exclusivity with your content so if Dan
and Justin develop other shows or
spin-offs of Rick and Morty then they
have to give those to Adult Swim before
they give those to other networks so
they're probably gonna develop other TV
shows for Adult Swim in the next seven
years or so but a lot of that is a long
ways off so don't worry about it right
now they literally just started working
on season four it takes them about a
year to turn episodes around which is
why I say that next July is probably the
earliest that we're gonna get season 4
Comic Con is happening at the end of
July just like it was last year they
usually bring animatics or at least some
early work on what's gonna be coming
down the pipeline it takes too long to
animate stuff so I don't expect them to
bring an actual trailer for season 4 or
anything like that but during that long
wait between season 2 in season 3 they
did come to comic-con with an animatic
for what ended up being the pickle Rik
episode so they can turn that around
that fast and they could probably do
something similar for whatever Comic Con
panel they end up doing this summer so
it's a couple months away don't worry
but in the meantime to celebrate what
they've done is Adult Swim has sent the
Rick mobile if you remember that from
last summer they're gonna be touring the
[ __ ]
reselling Rick and Morty merchandise so
if you went to the Rick mobile last year
it'll be the exact same deal this year
citing mr. poopy butthole big white
Santa Claus beard conspiracy theories
people thinking Christmas episodes it's
possible if season four takes a little
bit longer to get out then it's next
winter before we see new episodes but
what will probably happen is is is that
in the next seven years or so or however
many seasons they break these 70
episodes up into is is that every couple
of years there will probably be some
production delay that they can't
anticipate so what might end up
happening is is we get season four next
summer and then we get each season a
year after that on a more regular
schedule because they know that they've
already been renewed for those next
episodes so they can just keep the
animators working on new episodes
year-round to keep those episodes
rolling on a more regular schedule but
if there is a break you might wind up
with a situation whereby in like season
five or season six there might be that
year break between seasons again but for
the most part the reason why they
probably renewed it for 70 plus episodes
is because it's so profitable for them
and they want it on a more regular
schedule so they want Danna Justin to be
able to plan ahead and there's a certain
amount of security built into that as
long as they're able to keep the quality
up there's no worries they could just
keep working as much as they want but
what'll probably happen is is when we
get to the comic-con panel this summer
they'll probably give us some more
details about what their plans are for
the future seasons like hey we're gonna
try for 14 episodes for season four or
we're only gonna do seven seasons of ten
but I wouldn't be surprised if the
episode count for some of the later
seasons fluctuates a little bit just
depending on how production goes along
but Adult Swim or during that giant
block of episodes reminds me a little
bit of the 90s animation like Batman the
Animated Series the Fox Warner Brothers
cartoons like Animaniacs instead of
buying a season of episodes what they
would do is they would buy a block of
like 90 episodes the animators would
produce those and then the network would
just break those up into a bunch of
different seasons so instead of having a
big hiatus between seasons like a lot of
live-action television shows do the
animators just work year-round until
they get all 90 or in the case of Rick
and Morty all 70 of those episodes done
obviously it's gonna take them a while
to get started like the people that work
in the past might come back some of them
have already worked on two other
projects so I could talk about this all
day but let me know in the comments what
do you think about this and would you
rather see them do five seasons of 14
episodes of peas or 10 episodes of
season four seven more seasons but just
to be clear you know ninety seven more
seasons just because they only got a 70
episode pickup doesn't mean that at the
end of those episodes they won't renew
it for more so if everything goes well
let's say that this gets broken up over
the next five years at the end of that
Adult Swim renews them for another
couple of seasons
if ratings continue to hold up but just
to be clear this is so much more popular
than anything else that Cartoon Network
our Adult Swim has ever done that they
could continue making this till the end
of time and even if ratings slid it
would still be more popular than
anything else that they've done so it's
kind of like Game of Thrones with HBO
like HBO will do everything they can to
keep airing new Game of Thrones till the
end of time so I wouldn't worry too much
about what happens after these 70
episodes like I said the season 3 DVD is
dropping really soon here's a deleted
scene from episode 6 every word now
let's see how he enjoys living in that
[ __ ] tank he's right behind me isn't he
he's in front of you my eyes are still
adjusting you lied to me oh ho I'm
healthy Rick someone lied to me I'm
gonna die of sadness sea cucumber sea
cucumber after 70 years of being bottled
up and sentimental jackass I finally get
to live my own life you said we were
merged at live dumbass I lie about
everything why would I ever reemerge
with a [ __ ] like you so you were just
gonna trap us in that tank that was your
plan not was [ __ ] still is Oh
kill him I like this this is scary right
you asked for it did I ask for assessing
threat to growing the right system 6000
killem that is my groins you sir believe
me I got a lot more use out of that
thing than he ever did you know what not
my table
so what'll happen is is I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post new Rick and
Morty click here for that last season
for teaser and click here for all my
other season 4 videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]